[Music]
hello i'm greg jarboe and the content
marketing faculty chair at market motive
and this is a short course on youtube
and mobile video and in this first
module we're going to sort of share with
you not the 40 tactics that you probably
need to use to be successful because
this is the short course but what we're
going to talk about are the seven most
significant ones
if you try to figure out what those
seven are you might come up with the
list but let me share it with you
because it's the outline for this short
course first thing is you've got to make
you to the key part of your social media
marketing strategy I know it probably is
it may be but we're going to tell you
where it fits and why probably isn't
getting the kind of resources that it
deserves in this first part we're also
going to talk about how you can create
the type of video content that your
target audience will want to watch and
we're also going to talk about
scheduling your videos and optimizing
your content and then in the next module
we'll get to the rest of top seven
strategies so let's begin with the first
thing that you really have to get your
arms around it turns out according to
recent research YouTube is the largest
video sharing site I'm sure that doesn't
shock you
you knew that part but it's also the
largest social media site in the United
States and that may surprise you in
other words YouTube has slightly more
unique visitors a month in the US than
Facebook and I can't tell you how many
people who have a social media marketing
strategy fail yeah yeah Facebook Twitter
Linkedin right need to have lengthen all
of those our social mediums those are
things that you should have programs
around but excuse me YouTube is too big
to be ignoring oh by the way there's
some other people say yeah but what
about Vimeo well Vimeo is on the list of
the top ten but it's in tenth place so
yeah let's start with YouTube in this
particular course if we have time to get
through the other nine underneath it god
bless you good luck but you know what
we're going to focus on YouTube now one
of the things that marketers have been
complaining about lately is that
Facebook has been taking away some of
the features that made it such a
wonderful place to do marketing on a
little harder now things are changing
things aren't working the way they used
to
even industry analyst at Forrester have
said you know what it's time to tell it
like it is
Facebook seems more interested in your
ad dollars and less interested in you
actually using it as a marketing
platform meanwhile at the same time
YouTube has been going through some
transformations and in order to be a
little more brand friendly one of the
things that they've done lately is
they've cleaned up the comments area
underneath videos and now they'll do
some auto searching for well let's just
put it this way hate words trolls
there's a lot of things now that you can
do to moderate the comments underneath a
YouTube video that actually makes it a
more interesting social media to engage
your prospects and clients with so I
think if you net all this out what it
means is is that yeah YouTube needs to
be a key part of your social media
marketing strategy and even if you don't
make it like number one on the list
which frankly I think it probably should
be it still needs to be right up there
it's not an after not thought it's not
something that you should get to when
you have the spare time it ought to be a
priority and that means if you've
delayed getting your arms around this
thing or while we created a YouTube
channel and we uploaded a few 30-second
ad spots and nothing magical happened
it's like yeah yeah
that's why you're here in the short
course let me tell you what you do next
one of the things that you need to
understand is what are people actually
watching and it turns out repurposed
30-second television ads ranks really
low on the list and if that's all you're
putting on your YouTube channel check
out what actually is being watched more
often than not it's everything from
product teasers to how-to videos in
other words there's ways to use YouTube
for marketing purposes way beyond a
repurposed 30-second spot this is also
true with b2b YouTube is a wonderful b2b
marketing platform in fact this is a
case study of a company called sama site
they're in the medical products industry
they sell the hospitals so it is a b2b
cell and they sell several hundred
thousand dollars worth of portable
ultrasound equipment and they used
YouTube quite effectively to surprise
surprise
shorten the sales cycle and in the b2b
cell that's money in the bank how did
they shorten it well there's always a
committee that makes these kinds of
decisions and not everybody on the
committee got to meet with the sales rep
and so not everybody in the committee is
fully up to the speed with features and
benefits of the product but if there's
video available of how the product works
all of a sudden a whole lot of those
questions that may slow up the sales
process get answered in sales get
completed in fact they were able to grow
their revenue twelve percent year over
year by basically using video to shorten
the sales cycle so you want to be able
to create the kind of video content that
your target customers watch the most and
trust me it is not hard to get corporate
approval to create how-to videos we're
not talking about you've got to convince
them to do more funny cats I mean that's
not what you want to work what you want
to use to market your products unless
you're selling cat food of course but
guess what you can create a range of
video content
that will engage your prospects will
move them along you know the purchase
process and at the end of the day can be
a key part of both your social media
marketing campaign and frankly your
content marketing campaign it's a pretty
useful stuff
now here's the bad news this is another
reason why people who tried to dabble on
YouTube haven't seen much success and
then came to the premature conclusion
that well this just doesn't work for us
the answer is they dabbled meanwhile a
whole lot of other people who've been
incredibly successful on YouTube are
uploading content if not daily then at
least several times a week and this
includes brands that you know frankly
are doing very very well as well as some
of the YouTube stars which frankly all
of us should watch because we can learn
a lot of interesting lessons from people
who you know have built their own
franchise on YouTube so you know
surprise surprise
you need to start thinking about how to
act we go about creating more content I
mean that's going to take effort well of
course it does well it helps to have a
plan
and it helps to understand that you can
have more than one type of video one
type of video that YouTube calls hygiene
content to define this in sort of terms
that I think most of us marketers would
understand and might want to reuse
around the boardroom table we can do our
keyword research discover which
questions people are asking on YouTube
and then create videos that answer those
questions one of the people who does us
incredibly well is Matt Cutts of Google
you know every one of the videos is he
is uploading on almost a weekly basis is
Matt you know I just got this question
from a guy named Matt and let me answer
it well sometimes Matt writes questions
to himself so it must have no slow week
but the point is is compelling viewing I
mean those of us in the industry who are
trying to keep up with the latest
wrinkles at Google or watching that
videos every week so that's one type of
content you can also create a web series
where if it's Monday then we're going to
feature yet another one of our wonderful
customers talking about how they're
using our product in their industry or
business and then occasionally you can
create something
really special and the people who sort
of taught me this trick or over at the
discovery digital networks and I don't
know if you've heard of it but there's
something called Shark Week and who
invented Shark Week the people at the
Discovery Channel and when does it
happen some week in August and what does
it feature a whole lot of video about
sharks and who declared the Shark Week
well they did they made it up you can
make stuff up too so whether you're
doing QA whether you're doing ongoing
series whether you're doing something
special once a year guess what you can
build out a programming schedule just
the way those big con shows up at NBC
ABC and CBS do for every fall you can do
it for your annual YouTube channel so
key to being successful key to being
effective develop a programming strategy
and then plot out your content because
you know what it's a heck of a lot
easier to create more content if you're
not trying to pull a rabbit out of your
hat every other week it helps if you
have a plan because then suddenly you
can shoot half a dozen episodes on the
same day you just happen to upload them
over the next six weeks that's a way to
keep your budget sort of in line and
your production capabilities don't have
to grow beyond what you can afford and
yet you know you now have a heck of a
lot more content that you can play out
over the course of a year
you'd also want to optimize your videos
so we can get found in search right
right but let me share with you the
first lookie mistake that most people
make when it comes to optimizing a video
they use google keyword tools to try to
figure out what terms to put on their
YouTube videos and pardon me when people
use Google to do a search believe it or
not they use different search terms or
in some cases they may use a same term
but in different volumes then when
they're on YouTube and let me just share
this quick example with you it turns out
that Google Trends now not only gives
you what the Google interest is in a
particular term you know they've had
that since day one but you know in the
last year they've also added a drop down
menu option to say oh I want to see
YouTube search trends so he's the same
tool to see both and this example here
shows the terms Chevrolet and Chevy and
in Google it's a horse race it's about
50/50 you know even steven you could
pick it either term what the heck in
YouTube it's no contest
Chevy has almost twice as many searches
on YouTube as Chevrolet and so this is
just a quick illustration that when you
want to do your video research you want
to use video research tools then of
course you want to optimize your video
and there's more to it than just putting
the right keywords in the right places
that used to work and it used to be
sufficient that's what YouTube calls
metadata so you want to put those
keywords in your titles and your
descriptions and your tags okay got it
YouTube changed its algorithm to include
something called watch time in other
words if people start to watch your
video and go yeah boring or oh corporate
propaganda and they stop watching you
don't have very much watch time and
guess what your video doesn't rank very
well
so you know surprise probably surprise
you're going to have to create some
pretty compelling video content or some
pretty interesting video content or some
how-to videos where nobody in their
right mind is going to bail out halfway
through and only know how to complete
half of the project in order to get your
watch time up and then last but not
least you certainly want to make sure
that your video is distributed and lots
of places why because the YouTube player
is sort of interesting in that if it's
embedded in a blog for example and
somebody watches the video by clicking
it and watching it while on the blog and
they never come to YouTube to watch the
video that view still counts and if they
watch it all the way to completion guess
what that counts in the algorithm back
over on YouTube in the watch time part
and so yeah find ways of not just
distributing your video but distributing
your video on places where it is likely
to be viewed and watch by relevant
audiences hopefully all the way through
to the end and I can be blogs that can
be your own website frankly it can be
your Facebook page it can be your
Twitter account it can be your LinkedIn
account it can be your Pinterest account
you know what you can share YouTube
videos to all of those and you should so
you want to be found you want to be
discovered you're gonna have to optimize
your videos and your playlists and your
channel in order to reach and keep your
audience why all of those because if you
do a search in YouTube you'll discover
that videos playlists and channels will
come up in the youtube search results
and let's not forget YouTube is the
world's second largest search engine
there are more searches done on YouTube
a month then are conducted on bing the
only thing that's behind is Google
itself so again optimize your videos
optimize your playlist optimize your
channel and help your videos get
discovered
hello again and welcome to part two of
the YouTube and mobile video short
course in part one we covered four of
the top seven things that you need to
focus on so let's start with part 5
most of us started off in the era where
if you optimize your video you could get
sufficient traffic to actually help it
get discovered these days there's more
than a hundred hours of new YouTube
video content uploaded every minute
and unfortunately the downside is that
makes it even harder for your video to
get found in organic search so I know
I'm going to sound like I'm straying
over into the dark side this is not the
dark side this is still a white Hite
tactic but one of the things that you
may need to consider is when to
jumpstart your campaign by using paid
media so here's some of the things that
you have to understand to understand why
that's a white hat tactic and by the way
it's a white heck tactic even YouTube
approves of this one of the things that
you need to know is that when you create
and add in YouTube one of your options
is not to upload a brand new video but
to take an existing video and promote it
in other words existing content can
quote be turned into an ad and what that
means is you can take the new video that
you've just uploaded it and you can sort
of do double duty you've just optimized
it and hopefully it'll get found for a
couple of search terms that you focused
it on but then you can use YouTube
advertising which is called TrueView
that's the name of their what Google
calls AdWords for video and what you can
do with this TrueView ad is take that
basically existing content turn it into
an ad and then have it displayed over
not two or three search terms which is
about what you can optimize it for
organically but you can actually
advertise it against hundreds perhaps
even thousands of relevant search terms
and what this means is is that your
video content your video surfaces when
someone does a search on YouTube and if
they click on it well that's then when
it's an ad in
and you pay for it so you know other
than the sort of the crossover where the
content came from okay got it
it's like AdWords it's an auction-based
system you know get it okay whatever but
here's one of the things that happens
and this is part of the mystery of
YouTube for every two clicks that you
get that you're paying for somebody's
going to watch that video and say wow
I'm going to share that with a friend of
mine and then their friend watches it
and when they share the video and the
friend watches it that's not an ad
because it's your same content and that
means you don't have to pay for it so
one of the things that YouTube has found
by examining over 6,000 recent campaigns
is that on average for every two paid
clicks that the paid advertiser is
paying for you they're on average
getting one free click again this helps
jumpstart your traffic it helps people
discover your video and oh by the way
the bonuses you get people to start
sharing your content if it's compelling
if it's informative if it's something
we're sharing you can get organic views
on top of the page gifts you can't do
that with regular Adwords and Google
trust me but you can do it with you too
so how do you succeed with TrueView ads
it's all different because in addition
to being like the auction-based system
in addition to being AdWords for video
you have a couple other options as well
one of them is you can run that ad as a
pre-roll in other words before let's say
somebody wants to watch a very popular
music video before that video starts
your quote ad which again can be regular
content that you promoted will appear
before the video that they wanted to
watch as a pre-roll ad or what YouTube
calls a TrueView in-stream format and
about five seconds in to your video
playing your ad starting YouTube does
something pretty amazing that they
pioneered and really blew me away the
first time I saw it
they put a little skip ad button at the
bottom of the video which means if the
viewer sees this as an intrusion I'm
sorry I wanted to go watch the music
video I don't want to watch this ad they
can click that skip it button and go
straight to the video and here's the
interesting thing for you as a marketer
if they skip your content you pay
nothing in fact they have to watch more
than 30 seconds of it before basically
the meter starts running and you then
pay per click Wow so again you're not
only getting organic views you know one
for every two that you pay for but you
also are getting people let's think
about this for a second the only ones
who I have to pay for the ones who are
interested in watching more than thirty
seconds of it you know frankly that's
pretty revolutionary so again if you
have not checked out TrueView ads you
you really want to they can do some
things for you that frankly we haven't
seen in any other kind of ad format out
there from anybody else so again the
net-net of this part you can leverage
paid video
to put your organic content in front of
the right audience
that's not something you might think of
doing because it's not a tactic that you
can borrow from somewhere else it is
unique to YouTube just as TrueView is
unique to YouTube just as a whole lot of
the other tactics so we're going to go
through in other words this is a big
opportunity
you know it's one that you want to get
your arms around even if it's a little
different
now another tactic that you're going to
want to use is you want to make sure
that your video is shareable it helps if
you've got content that is shareable but
even so one of the things that sort of
put YouTube on the map in the first
place the reason why it is known as a
video sharing site is because it has so
many wonderful options not only can you
embed the video on blogs or on websites
not only can you like email the URL to
people you know yeah yeah yeah got it
but you can also share it to Facebook
and Twitter and to Google+ and Pinterest
and a whole bunch of other social medias
and one of the things that you need to
understand is about Oh 500 years of
YouTube video content is watched every
day on Facebook and there are about 700
YouTube videos tweeted on Twitter every
minute so again you know it's not just
about YouTube in itself the YouTube
audience is distributed and that means
your video is going viral if it's
actually pretty interesting and all
those extra views can't now
understanding that that's what it takes
to be successful why aren't more brands
successful in fact they're pathetic in
some industries they account for
single-digit percentage of views of all
the videos watched in that genre or
industry at most in let's say the
electronics industry where they do the
best brand generated videos barely reach
you know in the mid-20s in terms of the
percentage of content that people are
watching in that category what happened
well what happened is most brands are in
a set it and forget it mode will put the
video up we're done and most of
successful channels particularly the
vloggers who are trying to make this
their living understand that it's also
about engaging your audience which means
when they post a comment you're still
and to respond and you know the
difference in engagement is night and
day and that's one of the reasons why a
whole lot of the amateurs are doing a
whole lot better than a lot of pros on
YouTube because the pros don't realize
that maybe hanging around for 15 minutes
after the video goes up is critical to
success so the net-net of this tactic
you absolutely want to amplify what your
video content says by socializing it
interacting with your prospects and you
can do it at scale because if you're
interacting with the first people who
respond to you in the first 15 minutes
everyone who comes by later sees your
response and they know the lights are on
there's somebody here who cares it
actually encourages them to say hey
there's a community I could I can build
it around this video that's part of the
secrets of the success
the other interesting thing that's worth
noting is that YouTube gives you YouTube
analytics now this wasn't always the
case there were no such thing is even
YouTube incited until 2008 analytics
wasn't rolled out until late 2011 but
now what YouTube is giving you for free
with your YouTube channel is a very
robust set of analytics to go frankly
beyond Google Analytics one of the
things you will not find in Google
Analytics that you will in YouTube
analytics is how people were watching
your video and when they stopped and if
you suddenly discover everyone's bailing
out 30 seconds in you got a problem
because you a you're not getting very
much watch time and what was it that was
happening at that 30-second mark that
everyone went there give me a break I'm
out of here
so there's a lot of things to learn from
your YouTube analytics if you can learn
not only did people watch it views has
been around and people have been paying
attention to that metric but it's one of
many you know one I urge you to look at
is your watch time and by the way which
search terms were people using to find
your video and guess what YouTube Scotia
shows that even if Google doesn't and
the other interesting things is you can
find out which videos people were
watching when they decided to subscribe
to your channel which videos triggered
people to share it to others on social
media so you can begin to find out where
people were interacting with you which
videos out of all the ones that you've
uploaded actually connected with the
community that's killer data
and why is it important because you then
need to bridge the next gap because most
of your executives are going to say well
that's nice people watch your video and
they shared it and that's great but what
they really want to know is did they
come to the website and did they buy
anything and increasingly it's becoming
a little easier it's still not perfect
to sort of bridge that gap you know in
some cases you can use cookies in other
cases you can use you know links that
are called annotations to get you from
the video over to your website but the
other key is beginning to use a
multi-channel funnels in Google
Analytics to begin understanding not
only where your traffic came from and
what they did next but oh by the way
when they came back to your site days
later weeks later and begin doing
something else in other words we may be
upstream generating people who come and
discover our companies or our brands or
our products early in the cycle and then
come back either having bookmark that
page or using organic search or come
back in some other fashion when they
decide to finally make the purchase so
again multi-channel analytics will help
you bridge that gap and at the end of
the day you know you really want to put
the other the right key performance
indicators the right KPIs to make sure
that you're measuring the success of
YouTube strategy and that goes way
beyond measuring views
one of the most frequent questions I get
asked is well how long should a YouTube
video be well the answer is how long
does it take you to tell a good story in
other words there's no right time
there's either good stories or there's
not so good stories so they some of them
are short and some of them frankly are a
little longer and unfortunately too many
marketers have drawn the assumption that
short is required and they are making
videos that are 2 to 3 minutes long and
figuring well that's it right
interestingly enough new research from a
company called Pixability says well
there are a group of people that will
watch videos that are 2 to 3 minutes
long that's okay
but even more are watching videos that
are 3 to 10 minutes long in other words
if it takes you a little longer to show
people how to do something take the time
to tell them how to do it and don't try
to force it into the 3 minute limit you
know at the end of the day they want to
be able to complete the job not to get
an overview of it so take the time to
tell your story
now that's enough that's the end of part
2 in part 3 we're going to actually
shift gears a little bit we're going to
take a look at mobile video and again as
Calvera told his Bend it's in the movie
the Magnificent Seven enough we can
always get the rest when we come back
[Music]
hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simple
learn Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here